Dylan Gibbons six-foot-six 315 pounds
Notre Dame offensive tackle from in deal
I'm gonna call you one day they called
me dad and call him daddy because he
knows how to eat
oh dear it's American Grill in Tampa
Florida you may take on the burger
challenge sir is ready to be not
terrified but it's alright so this
challenge has to be completed in 30
minutes are you ready I'm ready
all right actually you actually brought
something for the exact stop it no we
got one sauce you can eat a burger and
of course sir all right I gotta stick
around dude antacid tablets Wow feel
like I'm gonna need those getting kind
of worried here just breathe
okay yeah I like stressful good shrink
the stomach I'm no scientist but that's
what b.o.b says golf on the games for
the meat sweats breaking I think here
that surgery now officially ten minutes
in you have just less than one patty
left you're in good shape
me not so much
we have five minutes left on the clock
you got to leave me behind and try
finish this
alright done first thing thirty minutes
not enough time second of all I was
pretty awful I think you did pretty
great how would you say you did I would
say in between I did it did better than
expected definitely I'll be back I'm
gonna finish what I started at the end
of the day we made a great team we
didn't go Irish